the haunting of Hill House is not a new
show it came out last year on Netflix
and I watched the entire first season
and I'm just now getting a talk about it
why is that busy as fuck probably the
best way I can describe it now that
we've got that out of the way let's talk
about what I think is the best new TV
show I've saw all last year this show
was fucking phenomenal I loved every
single episode and much of this is due
to the creative
I will just say genius of Mike Flanagan
I have been talking about this man since
oculus after oculus I went back and I
watched his film absentia made for a
shoestring budget with some people he
knew in an apartment that he rented and
I have followed his career through great
movies like hush and I'm ecstatic to see
just how great this show was this is
without a doubt the best anything that's
been made out of that original source
there was the 1963 the haunting the 1999
the haunting and now this which has been
adapted from Shirley Jackson's book and
it's easily the best out of all of those
this is super super creepy fucking shit
I really enjoyed the show from beginning
to end if you don't know what the plot
is or you haven't seen the show on
Netflix it's basically about Hill House
and the family members that were there
as kids how it affected them then the
hauntings that went on there and how it
affected them as adults it's not just
about a ghostly haunting this is a very
haunted family it's not always about
ghosts it could be about an author who
wrote a book and his family is extremely
bothered by the fact that he put all of
that out there and they're angry with
him it's also about how one of them has
a severe drug problem how he's in and
out of rehab and his family's trying to
care for him every single one of these
family members is in some way shape or
form affected by their experience at
Hill House and how it shaped them into
the people they are today and so it's
not just a really scary well-made drama
horror it's also an extremely effective
tragedy every episode builds from the
last and the scares get better and
better and better I loved all of the
ghosts I loved how Mike Flanagan set up
the ghost I have said this for years
he's one of the best horror directors
working today
and I'm so excited he has dr. sleep in
the pipeline I can't wait to see that
film I'm just glad that people are
starting to notice his talent like
really because I thought oculus was just
so fuckin good and I'm just glad that
more people are starting to notice I
made the mistake of often watching this
show before bed sometimes I'd like to
put on something before bed to sort of
relax a little bit and I'm not saying it
scared me and made it so I can't sleep i
watch creepy shit before bed all the
time the mistake was that I was so
invested in the show that I kept wanting
to watch the next episode and I didn't
go to bed what's the problem because
it's just that investing I'm sure most
of you have probably seen the show by
now because this review is late but if
you haven't please do check it out if
you have Netflix especially it's it's
there you can just access it right now I
think it's one of the best horror TV
shows in regards to debuts I've ever
seen if they do make more I'm excited if
they don't that's fine it's perfect I
like the way it led off the ending was a
little unpopular for some people but I
liked it I really thought it was
different and kind of mature a Henry
Thomas holy shit great to see him in
this show what a great actor I'm so glad
he's getting more respect because I've
liked him a lot in things like psycho
for when he played young Bates Norman
Bates really great actor and I'm so glad
he's getting more work this show really
gave me everything I wanted and more and
I'm glad that so many people are
appreciating it I'm gonna give the
haunting of Hill House an a again I
apologize the review was so late it just
became one of those things where I was
gonna do it and then something else came
up gonna do it something else came up
and then it became easy to push off
doing the review but I got it done I'm
looking forward to more if they decide
to make more guys thank you so much as
always for watching and if you like this
you can click right here and get stuck
mine eyes
[Music]